[Music]
we dip hello babe how you doing who's
this this is babe babe
in my seat I I have a tweaked neck
anywhere it's kind of not to sacrifice
and now you see it is hard this is this
is tough that's a hard scene I do that
yeah I do that whenever we have a guest
yeah yeah you never sit here I've never
sat there once but I don't know what it
feels tougher for the guests now no I'm
okay though because I'm I'm used to
talking to two people yeah
yeah
yeah it's it's I never thought about
that that you get you gotta move a lot
maybe that's why your camps are in such
good shape because you move your head so
much your plane says he plants his feet
place his feet I dig in yeah wow Arizona
Iced Tea what are those air walks uh no
these are the day Adidas Arizona
ginseng lemon yeah this is a gift from
our friend Brian Q Quinn he picked up
himself and he got me these yeah they
got them today they got into the young
people's game now they did yeah I don't
know what I'm doing with them you guys
have good sneakers you guys uh he helped
me out big time yeah I used to be a
straight up like shell top coals
clearance like Adidas yes like that was
it fresh but then we went like shopping
once or twice and I I enjoy it do you
mostly just do Adidas oh mostly right my
Arch game is great in these eyes yeah
mostly with the Nike blazers you like
those I like Nikes I like Nikes I have a
new pair of Nikes he noticed when I I
saw you recently I had them on and you
noticed them you said that's a good shoe
oh yeah yeah yeah low top or high top uh
that is at uncharacteristically a high
top for me interesting I like my ankles
exposed you never know what they're
going to get into yeah yeah you never
wear high tops yeah why is that
um it's an ankle injury waiting to
happen it can't it comes from when I was
used to play basketball in eighth grade
I used to hate to put on my high tops
and I think I never when I was able to
pick my own shoe I never went high top
okay yeah because I wasn't good at
basketball I blame the shoe but then you
then you killed at bowling in high
school oh yeah but that's a that's a low
top unbelievable bowler yeah
unbelievable speaker Bowlers Yolanda
Vega was on the show a couple of weeks
ago I know I saw her last night Yolanda
did you had a bowling outside at my show
in Albany and and Yolanda unbelievable
person Yolanda Vega great person I was
trying to do some crowd work bits with
her trying to do we tried to meet up to
bowl yeah she rolls she rolls big time
what happened though she does she's a
big time bowler real-time bowler what
happened though and I was kind of I was
kind of um preparing Joe for this what I
was about to tell you uh here on the
show is I couldn't make bowling with
Yolanda Vega on Sunday in Albany because
on Saturday in Ithaca
the food that I ate
in the 10 hour window that I allowed
myself to eat
I'm in a playful mood today
as you know as I've as I've as I've
asked throughout the last few six uh
I've asked many times in the last six
months if I could have a moment of time
to discuss intermittent fasting I've
I've asked many people that and I've
given moments of my time to discuss in
fasting I have rules that I stay in this
certain eating window 10 a.m to 6 p.m
five days a week but Saturday I go off
the rails that's what it says tell us
what happened to Anthony tell me what
was on the menu I'll tell you what
happened to you so how do I go off the
rails yeah and I think what happened was
is I worked out so hard in the morning
because I was like I'm gonna eat bad
that I actually overdid it and I pushed
myself way over the line
working out and the diet so
my eating began at 11 A.M on Saturday in
Ithaca I'm sorry on Saturday what time
did the feeding begin feeding began they
filled the trough at 11 A.M Saturday at
11 A.M I apologize in Buffalo Ithaca was
a two-hour drive from Buffalo he doesn't
even know where he was yes that's how
bad he got it yes it shows at Buffalo
State two shows at Buffalo State College
shows two but not College shows shows on
a college campus but not College shows
it's very interesting concept okay not
that is the theater was there at Buffalo
State but it was not a college show
which was interesting it was actually
good shows so
I start at 11 A.M at Buffalo shout out
Paula's Donuts I want to shout out
Paula's Donuts I went in there I had a
cannoli cream donut big one I had one
for breakfast yeah yeah you're talking
to the cannoli King that they inject it
can only mini cannoli on the top for for
garnish yep great his dog's name is
cannoli and his company's name is
cannoli I'm not kidding with Canola okay
so it's cannoli donut Google polish
Donuts Buffalo cannoli Donuts yeah
so I had a cannoli donut a peanut butter
and jelly donut amazing oh a bacon egg
and cheese everything bagel oh on an
everything bagel don't catch up two of
them
a bacon egg and cheese on everything
bagel ketchup donut two times two of
them no donut okay no no donut bacon
eggs no you didn't have two no Paula
Gets In The Bagel game as well I did I
did I had two two donuts and two big
Donuts they're not these are not okay
big real these are like custom Donuts
dessert Donuts there it is cannoli donut
specialty donut right there sticking out
yeah it's got it looks got a snout yeah
so that two bacon egg and cheeses two
Donuts a large iced coffee oh okay I say
to myself Chris you gorged yourself you
Gorge yourself even though we're going
to Ithaca which is gorgeous that's what
they say that's their what I said you
Gorge yourself you put the gorgeous
gorgeous so that's at 11 11 30. I've
consumed this I've consumed already
where two thousand cows right or we're
approaching
so I say you know what the only way to
to kind of balance this out I gotta go
get a salad I gotta get a salad I'm not
even hungry but I'm like because I you
know I had a nutritionist tell me once
stop focusing on what the bad food
you're eating focusing on focus on the
good food so don't worry if you have
donuts and pizza have the salad have the
vegetables start there so I said let me
go old school and do that and I have a
salad I have a salad grilled chicken I'm
feeling good right 12 30 we're driving
to Ithaca
no problem we got to Ithaca good I had a
uh you had a salad while you were still
in Buffalo yes before 12 30. yes it was
in transit I had a grilled chicken salad
there was a deli in Buffalo I went in
there and I had to make unreal go ahead
so and I'm full I feel full but I'm like
it's Saturday it's my day to eat it's my
time to shine so two Donuts two bacon
egg and cheese uh Bagels
iced coffee grilled chicken salad and
now we're hitting Ithaca now we're
hitting Ithaca so driving to Ithaca so
we get to Ithaca you're gonna have some
Anne Frank soon right yes so we get into
Ithaca so we get there we go to this
place I think it's called Reds Red's on
the Square red something
I proceed to go in there it's uh maybe 1
30 now well maybe let's say let's call
two o'clock are you at Sergio I was with
the great Mike Hammond my Canada my
Cannon uh Patty clips and Tommy tour
manager Tommy hair and so where we go
into Reds and I order a
um chicken chicken bacon ranch sandwich
french fries a white pizza which was
called The Betty White Pizza
I said it was for the table but nobody
else wanted it so I ate the whole thing
any pizza is a personal that's his move
yeah he said he just ordered us for the
table and it was 30 things and no one
eats it with him yeah so a Betty wine
flatbread this chicken sandwich waffle
fries then they proceed to tell me that
this restaurant has rotating custom
homemade ice cream cake and rotate and
custom-made cheesecake so I say what's
the ice cream cake of the day what's the
cheesecake of the day they tell me the
ice cream cake of the day is s'mores ice
cream cake I say well add one they say
the cheesecake is red velvet I said give
me two because I love red velvet who
doesn't so now there's ice cream cake
and red velvet cheesecake okay when you
say is it a cake or is it slice slice
got it red velvet I ask everybody at the
guys at the table do you want any of
this Mike says no Tommy took one bite
and Patty Clips was like I really
shouldn't so now I've eaten I an entire
piece of ice cream cake and two pieces a
piece and 75 one and three quarters
piece of 1.75 1.75 a piece of red velvet
cheesecake yeah so great so I'm like
Chris you have to stop I know it's your
day to go crazy but you generally have
to stop also what do you do before the
show to make sure you don't explode well
this is what I forgot I forgot he was
working I forgot that's what happens I
get into grooves where I'm having so
much fun during the day I forget that I
have to do this I forget I completely
forget that I'm even there for the show
I'm like I'm just hanging out
so we go
I go I gotta take a nap the Knicks were
playing they were getting their asses
kicked they said let me this is 3 30
right now we got the show at seven let
me just calm down let me go back to the
room whatever I take a nap I fall asleep
from 3 45 wake up at 4 30 quick 45
minute powering out but it's one of
those you wake up you don't even know
where you are I thought I was like back
in sixth grade one of those I wake up I
am starving
I don't know why I don't know how I am
because of the intimate investing I took
an edible the night before with my
cannon that I think maybe was a delayed
hit or something was going on with my
neurochemistry was he edible inside your
intermittent fasting window or did you
break it just for the edible no the
edible the edible was inside the
intermittent fasting window okay good
morning yeah yeah anything over 30
calories breaks a fast oh okay really
yes that's true oh so I can't have my
athletic greens it's 50 calories 50
calories to know but what you can do is
go naked greens when I do those are 25
calories with a shot of apple cider
vinegar which is zero calories okay go
naked green superfood okay uh I have I I
gotta tell you whenever you're not with
me you go shopping and you do light
drugs and light drinking like drugs and
electric but you never do it with me
heavy eating yeah so but we're gonna
have a day we're gonna change them we're
gonna have a day I'm gonna come over and
we're gonna do it when we when we live
stream the first episode of I think you
should leave season three okay that's
what we'll do okay so then I wake up I
the the food at the hotel that I was
shout out to Marriott at the Ithaca
Commons they have like a gourmet room
service manual release yes so I ordered
an applewood bacon uh applewood bacon
cheeseburger
I'm not lying an apple would bake a
cheeseburger french fries and a side of
macaroni and cheese
and I it is now it's five o'clock and I
eat all of that with a Diet Pepsi
we get to the show the balls to order a
Diet Pepsi
I cannot believe what I've done to
myself like I truly I'm like anger I'm
almost like emotionally like gonna cry
about what I've done because stuff
that's going on inside your body
especially because you're used to
intermittent fasting at that point is
like you're probably Shell Shocked I
can't no I almost think what happened
was it sent my brain my brain got so
overwhelmed by this that it wasn't
saying that we were full it was saying
oh there must my brain must have said
there must be something wrong with our
systems because there's no way he just
put 25 000 calories in us before 7 P.M
there's nobody did that right we missed
it we missed it we [__] upset he's he
has nothing in his stomach we've got to
keep him hungry yeah so I get to the
venue on Saturdays board up you board up
your windows on a Saturday on Saturday
on Saturday Tommy Tommy tour managers
just knows on Saturdays when I'm usually
typically I like pizzas in the green
room because I'm not fasting and
typically that'll be the one thing I'm
doing so he has two pizzas in there for
me one regular one pepperoni just zero
body wise zero Betty White it's like
full pizzas yeah so I say to the guys
Mike I come in here I can't eat this I
can't have a bite of this right good
Mike takes a bind to the pepperoni goes
this might be one of the best pieces of
pizza I've ever had in my life I was
like the [__] out of here it's we're in
Ithaca he goes dude try this pizza I was
like I can't
he goes dude I'm telling you this is
awesome
I eat the pizza the pepperoni pizza it
was maybe the best slice of pizza I've
ever had truly in my life I know it was
like it was well done it was
unbelievable
by the time
it's I the show was at seven we had a
delay start at 7 10. Mike goes on stage
at 7 15 ish I had to go on at 7 40.
7 30 I had eaten another seven slices of
pizza five pepperonis and two regulars
I'm not kidding then crust no regular
[__] pizzas five pepperonis and two
regulars
so I now walk onto stage I'm sweating
I'm like I I I'm almost like I don't
even need a regular meal before a show
not even one little meal I don't know
what the [__] happened to me I go out on
stage have not really that good of a set
because I'm like bowed down really I
call it yeah
surprise surprise you're a walking
carbohydrate yeah I call my Cannon about
40 minutes into my set I call Mike from
the stage I'm like Mike I need you out
here because I start to get light and I
throw it's gonna pass out I'm like just
come on stage we start doing crowd work
we start just doing this improvised
two-man show just to get through another
20 30 minutes give to people you know
what they paid for some value I'm like
tell them like I can't believe I do this
I got to go back to my room blah blah
blah
Tommy goes that place Reds texted and
said that they have the chef wants to
make you fried chicken mac and cheese
it's like his specialty fried chicken
mac and cheese so I'm like I really like
there's no way I can eat that I go there
I had went to Reds again again I had two
bowls of fried chicken two bowls of
fried chicken mac and cheese a tequila
and soda
and one more piece of the s'mores ice
cream cake who the [__] are you amazing
I did the math with my friend who's a
doctor he guesstimates that I had twenty
thousand 32 000 calories in one day is
what he guesstimates I did I went tried
to go to the gym the next morning Sunday
morning I've gotten myself up where I
can do like five sets of ten pull-ups I
could not do one pull-up I could not do
one pull up my body it was like um like
it didn't have anything like like my
muscles were like shaking like I I was
because you were starving this yes yes
yeah it like had this reverse thing and
I just it was one of those things where
I can't like I'll pay for that and I'll
feel that for the next week or two the
[__] that I took at The Green Room in
Albany I never never thought I'd say
this but I would I'd like to see it it
was a full Pizza no what I [__] first of
all one of the shits that wasn't how
many fl I mean that was continual [__]
right yeah they have a Loch Ness no I
[__] came out of the water I [__]
continuously for about 45 minutes did
you flush or did you just let it pile
about it I would have went to multiple
bowls
how does your body remember to keep
flushing the toilet and it was one of
those things where I I couldn't believe
that I could do that that I had that in
me and it's like a little scary it does
make me feel confident that I could keep
it in line most of the time but I had 32
000 calories in one day this Gotta Be
You Could I wonder if you could have
done any like damage to eat 32 000 I
don't think the human body is capable my
boys the doctor said like he would
advise me not to do that again you ate
15 yeah yeah
one doctors yes
you ate exactly 16 times what you were
supposed to eat in one day yes yes did
you you had to have gained five pounds I
hundred percent had to have I'll tell
you what today you know this was two
days ago I worked out today and I am
significantly less strong when I looked
at my body I was like wow dude you look
like you get like you're getting like
tits again and I didn't feel that way
three days ago when you're doing the
intermittent fasting are you eating
healthy in those windows as well are you
eating what you want but it's in a small
window I'm eating 75 healthy I would say
in other words I will have like today
I'm in My fasting window I had you know
egg whites avocado cheese and onions but
I had it in a wrap so it's like the real
healthy way would be just have that on a
plate with a side side but I had it in a
wrap what are you doing eighteen six
typically now it's eight sixteen eight
or eighteen six but more days it's
eighteen six let's call it Seventeen
seven okay
it would not be possible in 24 hours due
to time limitations looking through a
few websites the highest document the
amount any person had eaten was fifty
thousand calories in 24 hours by 750
pound man in my defense I was very
hungry
next was professional bodybuilders can
eat 30 000 calories per day when bulking
up so that's what I do so you started
your bulk right in time for summer there
you go yeah you imagine 30. so it was it
was it was one of those things where it
was it was bad oh and then I ate um
because I got Japanese Oreo cookies for
the kids and I ate they don't come in
sleeves in Japan they have little
pouches I ate a pouch of the uh of red
velvet Oreo cookies you know high and
drunk off my mind in the middle of the
night Saturday Sunday
high and drunk off your mind you're a
different person when you're not with me
it was really really bad you know I
start I really get crazy when I started
I I like where is normalizer I like to
know what happened you unplug it so it's
so easy if you're not keeping track to
have like 5 000 calories yeah so he's
sometimes I'm like oh I ate okay today
and I I told up on like 3 500 calories
like how does that happen I thought I
ate decent yeah no it's so no just just
just that the the sandwich that joke on
us from Italy just that that chicken
sandwich and that alone that's 1800
calories easily and then the the shoot
that was stacked that high with them
it's all that high as well how much
sodium but 100 delicious 100 delicious
but you're right you're right so I ate a
sandwich just now but what I don't
realize is that sandwich was over 2 000
calories yes and but that's why for me
calories in calories out doesn't
necessarily work it's too much busy work
for me the only provable thing that's
worked for me is eating within a
designated time window and then not
eating again for a longer period of time
letting your body just use what you ate
the night before day before as as fuel
having 32 000 calories in one day I
don't know scientifically I probably
can't eat until next Thursday but that
but that that is the only way that's the
only thing that's worked for me and the
only thing that works consistently for
everybody is intermittent fasting what
was it that's right there was a stint
where I could well everybody you've
gained and lost lots of weight a lot
yeah your your your
um a yo-yo I'm a fluctuator you want a
fluctuating yes time for the fluctuating
yeah
you when you got down to down down down
yeah what did you do you vegan nasty
I did vegan for I saw the the
documentary game changers right and they
talked about how you could like because
I don't eat well I never did and we
always talked about how much damage I've
done to my body when I had children I
was like I want to stick around a little
bit more and it was very uh veganism had
a lot of it had a lot of like good um
arguments as to why to do it it helps
solve your body problem so I was like oh
let me try because it can't hurt me to
try it right so I did it and I did that
for eight months
and I lost my lowest I was ever down
besides L.A my lowest ever is La but
besides that I lost I was 225 at my
heaviest when we were in season six
seven ish 225
um and then I got down to 180 180.
I don't know that I'll ever be able to
get under 200. I know last time I was
under 200. when was it was 2007 or 2008
it was 199. right because I lost 55
pounds wow and uh I broke 200 and then I
hit 199 and I continued doing what I was
doing I never lost another pound
plateaued yeah I plateaued yeah so I was
like how do I how am I gonna lose more
and they're like now you have to go to
the gym and I was like well now I stayed
yeah my weight is that I'm like well I'm
in the 199 to 205 as well right now you
are I'm a 201 202 right now wow I saw my
stomach though that's why on that fat
arms you're one of those guys you don't
you you have your shirt off you don't
give a [__] you you're comfortable with
who you are yeah 100 well and you always
have that's crazy because I even because
I'm even when I'm 2205 maybe two I'll
take my shirt I've only seen it but I'm
not I'm not prancing around town with no
shirt yeah
no like swimming pools yeah well I will
say this in a in a private pool
no well well because well two things one
uh I started when I damaged all my skin
from that trip with Murray and I got uh
spots all over me and everything I'm
like I'm never doing that again because
it was it was overcast in Miami and I
didn't have a shirt on at the pool party
at uh [__] place you just went to
Fountain Blue yeah and uh I ended up
having to go to the hospital and I had
to sleep propped up standing yeah
and just
people to rub lotion on my skin so since
you love it I'm wearing like a a for the
Sun but
if I'm in a public pool I won't do that
because we're in the public I don't need
someone to snap an unflattering photo of
me and then then they have and then
that's out there for life into the pool
what oh you'll be surprised
yeah well even not even sitting in their
Chair by the before everyone's taking
videos this that the other so so I'm
like yeah I'll I'll stay
yeah my I've always had a confident
confidence in my body an unfounded
confidence but I don't know why that and
on a dance floor the two places where I
shouldn't have confidence tonight so
where where are you insecure then where
don't you have because when I was one I
wanted to answer for the rest of this
episode right yeah sure you want me yeah
oh my God
where would you say I don't have
confidence
I don't know if there's any Arena
anymore that I don't yeah I didn't what
even when I was dating I was pretty
confident all the time
um
you smell good maybe it's all natural I
just use some product in the in the tub
yeah
my top product yeah yeah I use uh what's
the name of that place in L.A la flama
la Flume it's it's a high-end like
number seven
uses
the best yeah I showed you Centaur did
you yeah one time I said smell this and
I open it up it's from oh no that was
something else that's okay yeah I
smelled lalabo in um the Thompson Hotel
in L.A no yes that's when I smelled it
for the first time in Amsterdam oh did
you yeah they had that I found it in L.A
they had in my hotel room they had this
stuff I'm like moisturizing the cream no
what is this I did the shampoo uh
conditioner the cream is what sucked me
in and I didn't found out about the
shampoo lines wait a second so what
there has to be something you're
insecure about there has to be something
because I can man who's just as
confident as you would buy used nine
times out of ten the biggest thing the
biggest insecurity is some is someone
with their body that's usually what it
is but it's not you but that doesn't
mean you're immune to insecurity no I'm
definitely I wouldn't say I'm immune
insecurity I'll find myself in
situations where I'm I don't know your
hair isn't your hairline no my hair I
don't care about that I just fell apart
a long time ago I keep the grades of
salt and peppers here
um I've been doing this since I've been
rocking it since 32. uh you know I've
always been kind of fat I had the big
nose
um big nose I have bad I have bad uh you
know Arch you know you know my back like
you don't care like you're like you know
like you look at me and you're like you
know what I'm a bald big nose fat piece
of [__] yeah
yeah and I love them and I love them I
love every ounce of them I love every
all the way down to this guy uh that's
good that's good because a lot of people
right I mean if you think about
security and being it's great it really
is ridiculous that how we get so hung up
on these microscopic things when it's
like we're only going to be alive for a
very short amount of time even if we
live to 100 and then it's like you're
some other energy but if people spend
their whole life worried about what
other people think when really nobody
really cares at all right like you're
doing 95 of what we do we do for
somebody else right but Joe seems to
live for himself which is not probably
very liberating which is not selfish
it's what you're supposed to well you
put it out there you care about other
people's feelings in other people's yeah
you know they're they're what nots but I
like to bring out the best in people too
yeah you bring out those nipples yeah
I'm sitting right here I sit here on my
flat pancake inverted nip and I don't
care about that what are you going to
worry about at this point like look at
you you look like you look at Greek god
next to me so I like being the low the
barrier yes of Entry right right why do
you like that because I think I like to
make people feel good about themselves
because I feel like
I get it
[Laughter]
I eat pounds and pounds I take 32 000
worth of calories yeah you were saying
that I was like I've seen him do this
like 10 times you know so Joe when I
just told you about my eating that it
did not Shock you you were like all
right the guy ate a little bit too much
today you've done that before I've eaten
yeah yeah I oh I'm an eater well it's
it's really what it is is the pastries
and the cookies and stuff like that
sweet tooth like Beyond a box of
pastries alone yeah cholesterol issues
blood pressure issues one time you ate
so much pastry on camera on camera yeah
Claire that was
this it was like this
and he got flush it and lightheaded and
he felt like he was gonna pass out we
had to call the ambulance was having a
great turn so I tell him to keep going
and I'm in the back getting checked out
by the medic the Amber
beat red sweat and they're taking this
and they were like does anything out of
the ordinary happened and he was like no
and I'm like what are you talking about
you just ate 8 000 calories in literally
four minutes yeah because for the joke
he ate it really fast so I'm like your
body can't handle that you just ate
eight thousand calories in five minutes
I was coming down off a sugar high in a
bad way in a bad yeah you're like
something
something's not right
he's like that
when uh we were filming you were getting
punished you were out in London or
Wickham Warriors
yes there's a there's a professional
soccer team out I I guess in Wickham
yeah the Wickham Warriors and we we
filmed the punishment on their field
with them the whole team and Joe and
James had to be in net as the goalies
and the whole team just kept kicking
balls professional soccer shoes
and they got just jacked immediately and
fell down to the ground and they kept
hitting him then at the end he didn't
know this but just I guess I don't know
why but all this impromptu they did an
impromptu pylon dog pile dog pile grown
men football players and I'm on the
bottom with Mark and Murray had just
fallen and so I was holding Murray but I
was like sitting up and this you know 40
grown Englishmen dude there it is a dog
pile on me and I'm on the bottom of this
but my leg is one way and my back's the
other way and I'm on the bottom of that
so are you screaming I am I'm screaming
to get over me I've even punched one guy
in the neck to get him off me I swear to
God I punched a Wickham right in the
throat he wouldn't get off he thought it
was funny like they kept jumping watch
it's this one [__] here
[Laughter]
and then he took us into the locker room
this is one of my best friends by the
way
he locked his body with my
my hip locked so I couldn't take I
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't
straighten my leg so one leg was just
locked so when I laid down on the floor
my leg was like this
all the way behind his back so I
sprained my shoulders
conference I was in a conference room in
the back they put us in a conference
room and I'm laying in his whole body
was pink like because it was I know the
pressure and about he was just bright
pink and he was sweating he looked like
a [__] candy yeah
they were touching his body and he's
going ahead
they're trying to unpop my shoulder like
thing on the floor because
we're like we're gonna miss the flight
what are we gonna do yeah and it took
like 10 minutes and they kind of like
they had to like move him slowly back
into his normal position you know those
Gumby toys yeah you know that you're
bend their arms and stuff that's exactly
what I look like my arm was like stuck
it was but it was you're so funny like
you're just so visually funny to me like
you're such a funny physical person that
like the way you were locked up and on
the floor because I was still making
jokes
something about like I know you were in
pain but like there's something about it
I'm so funny
you know what I mean well it seems like
you do yeah
no because there was still cracking
jokes
I remember they were telling me that we
said oh what happened I was like and I
called I said this one dumb [__]
Englishman kept jumping on me and I said
that to the medic as they're all
properly like oh what hurts and I'm like
just one dumb [__] Englishman kept
jumping on my shoulder [__] dude yeah oh
yeah that was wow yeah well I mean but
you know but you're good now I'm good
now no pain now no pain now see and
that's good and and and and that's what
it is some guy who's ripped shredded
takes care of his body might not have
been able to walk away from that but you
did yeah that's because I'm I'm around
that bounces right off me oh [__] six
and seven people worldwide plagued by
feelings of insecurity six and seven so
on the One You're The One seriously holy
cow that's [__] pretty awesome oh
that's wild yeah
we're all insecure in here I think
everybody's in security degree I just
don't have one thing that I'm like oh I
have moments of insecurity of course I'm
human but I don't think there's not one
thing I'm like oh you know don't yeah
don't make that up yeah I have tons of
insecurities I think but I don't think
it manifests himself in a way that makes
me an integral person exactly right you
know where you say uh what's wrong with
that person they're probably insecure
they're taking it out this way yes I
like just keep all man Securities to
myself right some people get crippled by
insecurity they can't yeah they can't
even do anything about it you know and I
can't I I that that I can't even I can't
relate to that stuff yeah
or or like when people can't bring
themselves to like you know be like when
something happens bad in life and
they're like oh and that's it and they
go down that downward spiral I just
never grew up that way oh I just never
end that way when something bad happens
to you and you're like oh this is it
it's over yeah
compound I I'm I don't I cut that [__]
off I really think too there was a
teacher one time said to me you're said
to the class he was like any news that
you receive it's your choice on how you
want to react do not let Society dictate
your reaction so he said I could tell
you anything from
you have two weeks to live to you want a
million dollars and it's your choice how
you want to take that information so I
always thought that I'd probably be
happy with the million said with the two
weeks
but but what what if you get the two
weeks and then you know for the next 14
days the next 14 days of your life my my
14 days are Doom and Gloom you're not
coming out Doom and Gloom at 14. I'm not
will you go with that I'm not gonna hit
you have 14 days to live and then go out
and be like
I'm [__] hang gliding into Yankee
Stadium
if you have 14 days to live with one of
those days would you go to a public pool
and take your shirt off yeah you'd have
to no I wouldn't waste my time you have
to well who cares if they want
somebody's pictures to have them one
last pick and then what are you gonna
die anyway yeah there's that thing of
the the maybe thing about good news bad
news that Chinese there's a proverb
about the Chinese farmer you know that
one I heard that once what is it so
basically there's this Chinese uh
there's a Chinese farmer right in his
son um he has horses on his Ranch and
his horse runs away and one of those
Neighbors comes over goes oh that's bad
luck you lost your horse she's like oh
yeah he says well maybe and the next day
the horse comes back and it brings two
horses with it and now he has three
horses that's great news he goes well
maybe and then the sun's trying to train
the horse and he falls off and breaks
his arm he goes all that's bad news he
goes well maybe and then the next day
the general from the Army come says we
are taking all Able Body boys to join
our army and his son's arm is broken and
he can't take him and he's like what a
turn of events multiple days
wow yes that's good I like that I like
that a lot that's a weird thing like you
never know what it is but in the same
vain you can never Rejoice with good
news wow that's a good point Joe that's
a good point that's a that's a loophole
I think yeah but I think that's the
point of life is like staying even right
even Steven don't get too high too low I
think you can celebrate but don't let
the celebrate don't let the pop the good
news and the bad news Define you right I
think we got to stay I think the goal of
this state is they even Stephen well
that's impossible right it is impossible
but we're trying we are trying that's
what that well that's what it is
everything's impossible you just try
every day you just try somewhere in my
life I got hit with a depression and
then my my capacity to be happy or
Overjoyed or excited or positive about
something hit a with a threshold a
ceiling and I remember how I was used to
be able to get like how excited or happy
genuinely I used to be able to get in my
life and I realized that nowadays or
since this is happening whatever it was
I
my my pure happiness and joy and fun and
everything is not the same type as it
used to be a lot of times now it's it's
my ceiling from being happy is lower and
also I tell myself hey you're supposed
to be happy right now so you're happy
right so I'm happy about this because
this is the good news I'm happy but I
don't feel the happiness well because
because I know the the event and the
actions that cause happiness haven't
changed what's changed I think is the
things that you've brought now into your
life you have more things taking up your
mind space and more things that you
worry about and cause unhappiness that
are disguised as happiness but they
actually cause unhappiness you have more
of those things in your aura and then
knows what those do is desensitize the
happy moments you have to let things go
more let me give you a pro let's go
around and do Proverbs okay so that I
there's also uh uh the two another
Chinese farmer no these are the monks
these are the monks I would assume
they're Chinese I would assume any type
of good wisdom or any type of thing
that's tattooable is probably started in
China okay
two monks walking tuba two monks yes two
months walking on on uh row two Tony
shaloops walking
down the road yeah right
and they're going to catch a bus okay
they're going to catch a bus take them
into town monks will take a bus get
these [__] monks
parts and everything
you want to take the bus right and then
they're about to go
trying to catch the bus and an old man
is walking across the street and he
really needs help getting across this
muddy road so the one monk stops and
helps to get that person across the road
and he's holding them and he gets them
to the other side of the road and that
makes the second monk stop to wait for
his friend they missed the bus now
there's no other buses coming and the
two monks have to walk and they're
walking and walking and he could you
know he could tell the one Monk Is angry
that the other one stopped and and then
they walk for five miles and the one
monk the anger finally the angry monk
says why the hell did you we missed the
bus you had to stop and help that person
we needed to get on the bus and the
other monk says I let go of that person
five miles ago
we're just walking you're still holding
you were holding the weight of that guy
for the five miles well I let him go I
left I I sat him down and I left him so
it's about you know that same it's it's
many different it's many different ways
to say the same thing yeah you know you
if I'm still walking but if I hold okay
yes but if I hold a cup of water I have
a cup of water held out it's the same
it's a cup of water you can hold that
five minutes ten minutes 15 minutes
after 20 minutes your arm might start to
fall and then eventually you're gonna
drop that cup of water nothing changed
about the water nothing changed about
the circumstances you're just holding on
to the water you hold on to the same
thing
that's a fun literal to theoretical
proverb I appreciate what you did there
the first one didn't really click with
them are you like I got this other one I
got backups I got the water that's what
it is your water I got the water one to
make it easy because he likes to
dehydrated yeah he does he's big on it
yeah it's big so so so so that's so so
you're holding on you're you're you know
that's you're you're taking someone's
Point you're you're taking the poison
expecting them to get sick it's not
gonna happen I always talk about like a
happiness meter like you have to fill up
because life sucks
across the board it's terrible yeah it's
terrible everybody tells you otherwise
is lying to you right it's terrible so
what you need to do and we have it good
and we do we're a lot we do even life is
terrible even though we have products
like hellofresh and better help and rock
talking about the Bluetooth and
Bluetooth we have great products and if
you can go put in that promo code hey
babe and find out but even with the in
spite of that in spite of the promo
codes you know go to Butcher box and it
makes it better but do I get a piece of
this yeah 100 right so yes what I'm
saying is the the the the thing is that
like you have to and life is just hard
across the board no matter what you do
there's death there's getting sick
there's people who care about her and
these things all happen in life but when
you will have moments of happiness you
need to be like oh okay this is why this
is why okay this is why it's good and
then as the bad stuff happens you just
let that deplete and then when you're
happy again you have to fill it back up
you don't fill it back up that's when
you get in the room here's a tip here's
a tip
what I do every day I have an alarm set
on my phone different times of the day I
don't know what Rhyme or Reason I do
this but I have an alarm on my phone and
it goes off randomly and it just says be
grateful because so many times I would
start to notice when I would get sick I
would get sore throat I would get a cold
and I would be like oh this sucks now I
got to deal with this for four days but
instead of thinking about all the times
where right now I feel perfectly
physically fit and healthy and I'm
feeling like I'm rocking 100 I'm not
saying how lucky I am how great I am
today so I start to do that now and now
when I get
see a little bit of an affirmation it's
a little bit of like you know what this
sucks but guess what this too shall pass
my friend and in a few days from now
with the right medicine with the right
breathing the right calories with the
right amount of calories you're going to
start to feel good so be grateful every
day you know it's like it's the opposite
with the uppage of my dosage of
medication yes yes
it's just be grateful every day
contribute to your mental health
contribute to your happiness every day
drop it in the buckets like dollar cost
averaging let's switch this to finance
let me dollar cost averaging you hit me
with the DCA let me hit you
then Sal and Joe I want to make sure of
course averaging from
dollar cost averaging it's not about
timing the market it's about time in the
market that's what we want to talk about
here today dollar cost averaging
historically
you're not going to time the market
rather it would be better to just give
money every week play the long game in
the long game the stock goes up it goes
down over the course of a lifetime
you're pretty much guaranteed with the
stock market that's how I do it the
index funds you're going to get a 40
return as opposed to trying to time it
and sell and this and that those people
get much less returns dollar cost
averaging time in the market not timing
the market we can apply that to mental
health we comply with the finance we
could apply that to eating that's what
intermittent fasting is do you think
that your viewers what do you call them
the babers the babes the baby the babies
babes yeah I don't know we don't really
have a name for them babes babes we're
calling them it's called the babes do
you think that the babes they're sitting
there on their YouTube right now they're
on the youtubes.com right they're taking
backslash.com
there it is and then and they and
they're clicking and they're like oh
they just want to fast forward parts of
it just wanna hey I can't watch a whole
episode right now I just want to catch
parts of it and it starts with him
talking about how he took 3 200 calories
then we talked about me I take my shirt
off and then I'm underneath a bunch of
Englishmen and then we're talking about
depression and it comes to finance
advice do you think that their minds are
exploding oh this is a normal episode
you know kind of um a One-Stop shop you
get we talked about a little bit of
everything you know when you're
misbehaving when you're little and your
mom be like we'll say something like
don't be fresh yes this is the opposite
of that right we want fresh all the time
right and the fresh and hello fresh
America's number one meal kit that's
what we got yeah and that's what we're
giving to the people that's hella fresh
if you watch this pod then you know what
hellofresh is and if you watch for the
first time welcome you know what exactly
welcome you know what it means to us
okay right we we are first of all we're
Americans first and foremost that's what
we subscribe to is America's number one
meal kit that's hellofresh I was in the
Constitution George Washington everybody
who number one was yeah you are number
one here's the thing hello fresh does
more than just a little delicious thing
I don't believe you so I don't have to
explain your pick from 40 weekly recipes
but get this you can choose from over
100 items to round out your order from
snacks and easy lunches to desserts and
Pantry Necessities everything arrives in
one box on delivery day that you choose
that you choose and people say oh I'm a
pescetarian well I got news for you yeah
they got fit and wholesome to
pescetarian to veggie meal plans that
fit your needs whatever types of food
you want to eat hello fresh got you
comfort that's right hellofresh cans
about quality that's why they're
seasonal ingredients are picked at Peak
ripeness and have uh travel from the
farm to your home in less than seven
days so you know they're fresh and you
know it's May so we're celebrating Asian
American and Pacific Islander heritage
month month as we do each and every year
in my household and that's why they got
nice Asian inspired meals that are fresh
for you from very famous chefs like Chef
serbi Shani a New York uh you know who's
the chef at New York City's tag Mo tagmo
you're it
go to hellofresh.com hey babe one six
and use the code hey babe one six to get
16 free meals plus free shipping okay
that's go to hellofresh.com hey babe one
six and then use the code hey babe16 for
16 free meals plus free shipping uh
America's number one meal kit is
hellofresh
I love rocket money I use it Sal uses it
how many unwanted subscriptions do we
have that we forgot about well rocket
money which used to be known as true
bill is now taking care of that problem
for you you put in the information you
give the the information to the app and
they delete your unwanted subscription
on this it sounds crazy I did it it
works it happens it's very cool I
doubled up on my New York Times
subscription I was doubled up on my Hulu
subscription I had a gaming subscription
for Nintendo switch I didn't know I had
just thrown away money cashola amid cash
all rocket money is a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe
only dates I have available right now
only place it as tickets left September
23rd Hulu Theater Madison Square Garden
everything else is sold out if you want
to see my new hour of stand up Hulu
theater September 23rd New York City
Madison Square Garden it's going to be a
great show it's going to be fun we got a
lot of surprise guests coming in it's
going to be awesome and also there's a
lot of fun at patreon.com christycomedy
I'm going to start doing a new show over
there where you get your steps in with
me so it's called getting your steps in
with Chrissy so if you want are into
physical fitness and you want to get
your steps and get motivated go over to
patreon.com christycomedy and I'm going
to be your little box in the treadmill
it's going to be me so you get get fit
with me what's up guys we got some dates
in May June and July to round out the
Impractical Jokers tour and then more
dates will be announced if you didn't
see it so far all the tickets are on
impracticaljokerslive.com these shows
have been fun and outrageous we've had
surprises at them May 19th 20th and 21st
May 19th Arlington Texas College Park
Center May 20th at the Moody Center in
Austin uh May 21st at the Smart
Financial Center in Sugarland moving to
June Columbus June 2nd Cleveland Ohio
June 3rd and Detroit theater Fox uh the
fox here in Detroit on June 4th oh man
this is gonna be fun seanstein center
and Rocket mortgage field house that's
that's those are big shows June
um Minneapolis Des Moines and Kansas
City June 15 16th and 17th and then we
round out July here in Nashville at the
Opry on the 27th Cambridge Field House
in Indianapolis on July 28th and the
stifle theater two at two shows there in
St Louis on the 29th everything is
available at impractical jokerslive.com
and I will shortly be announcing
a second leg of my solo tour that starts
in July and will run through November so
stay tuned for that when is this coming
out pimpy
this Thursday okay so it's after may 10.
buy some merch check out our merch store
and check out savocano comedy.com for
updates my my Uber driver on the way
here I befriended him he was sweetest
man his name was Deepak and uh it wasn't
Chicago uh he was spitting knowledge to
me just about about this stuff what was
he saying Indian people are like that
they're very wise he was unbelievable
very wise well he was Italian
wait a stereotype oh okay uh no um deep
pork parmesan yes
uh
he was telling me what a trip he took
with his family okay and uh he it's
crazy he was a lawyer over there and his
wife was an anthropologist or something
like that and his kids asked was he in
what was the kid they go with the cat
system oh I don't know okay anyway my
point being is that he went on vacation
with his family and when they got there
the place that he booked was terrible
they wanted cash only it was seedy and
shady and they only stayed one night and
they left the next day and it was
smelling and he was like it was it was
the worst hotel I've ever stayed in was
the biggest mistake my whole family went
there we paid and then he goes and I was
like oh man I'd probably ruined the trip
it could ruin a trip he goes no
he goes because the way I live life is
if something bad happens I embrace that
because it only makes the good things
more noticeable and better like you have
to have bad have good which is you know
and but he he was just going off on like
for like 10 minutes in the car about all
this stuff and how he applied it in life
how many things and I was like I love
this man yeah yeah so I had this whole
kind of vibe coming here on the Uber and
that's the thing this is surrounding you
today yeah but you know what else though
we could talk about it to a blue in the
face I'll tell you what you told me I
know what we're supposed to do right
it's just that I cannot [__] apply it
I read The Power of Now 20 years ago 15
whatever it came out at cartola yeah
it's about
executing right that's the thing life is
execution right you can we have that
also his death
right so it's about the that's the and
that's the hard part we all have the
tools but to use the tools this is where
the game comes in so it's how do we find
ways to execute and that's that's that's
what you got to find what works for you
what works for you may not work for the
next guy oh it definitely doesn't
everybody everybody has to find their
own thing right yeah I would say but it
starts with the three of us you know the
three of us totally probably approaching
completely different ways I need to I
need to even
like remind myself to not sweat the
small stuff even all the time Kevin's
best special I get I like the greeting
card bit I get um I get like things in
my head that just like like they I can't
get them out you know what I mean I had
to like be like why are you this way
like why can't you just change
permanently I'm always fighting yeah the
way my brain wants to go yeah go ahead I
was just saying I've had a lot of
conversations with you over the years
because I've been one of your classic
confidants you know literally yeah you
know I'm all jacked up yeah I know
you're all [__] he's writing a book
about some of the concerts
it's on the shelves next year
um but I I think the biggest part is
like you take to heart like you get mad
that you're like the way that you are
sometimes and I think that's where it
all comes from instead of just accepting
like that's the way you are accepting
that's right if that's the way I am then
I'm going to be thinking negative
thoughts yeah but I think if you get rid
of the first first part of it and just
be like okay this is the way I am don't
be mad about that's that the way you
want you're saying that admitting that
I'm like that and just being comfortable
with is the first step in yes moving
forward from it I might be don't resist
but I do say that I'm like that I'm the
one who says it no but you get mad at
yourself but you resist it you're still
resisting yes you're saying you're angry
you say with anger resist yeah
this is something we talk about all the
time me and him this is the perfect
perfect example of me and Sal how we are
best friends and brothers meant to be
through the stars but complete Polar
Opposites okay a menu comes to the table
okay and we'll look I'll look at it and
I'll shut it and I'll be like I know
what I'm getting it right and then he'll
come and he'll be like oh whatever and
he waits to hear what everybody's having
but I'll already know what he had wanted
right he just has to listen to
everything take it all in he already
knew what he wanted an hour ago right
and that's the way it goes but then put
it in that we've been in business for 20
years together right and whenever a big
decision had to be made I would make it
like that and then Sal completely the
way you look at it is either he thinks
enough or overthinks it or whatever it
was and him and I nine out of nine and a
half times would come to the same
conclusion but he had his own process
where he would talk deliberate think
about write charts graphs Excel
spreadsheets of all this stuff and
that's just the way his brain works and
we would always end up almost always
right to the same spot yeah right yeah
so it's just who you are but that's I
have to make sure I am prepared I have
to do due diligence so that I know that
I'm not making an uneducated improper
but that's okay but that but but if you
resist that's who you want that's what
Joe has that's right that's where the
problems come in that's who you are so
you use it use all that energy use all
that energy that you do to graph out the
perfect you know weight loss plan for
yourself use all that energy to work out
the perfect family balance situation
sure sure do all that because we're you
know I don't I don't want to do like
it's been very impressive to me as well
you you you you you you talk to talk a
lot you do you do you you are you are
very self-aware and you put into
practice a lot of things that you preach
right that's noted just know over here
no do we note that
[Laughter]
I think that when I'm on a big kick on
and I think that this comes from you
know being a father and all that I
realize my older daughter and really my
12 year old stepson they have some
questions like recently that I didn't
know the answer like that or I hadn't
thought about it enough like Finance
learning
um the capital of Wyoming well Cheyenne
um um um he knows his capitals though I
love it I love that I love the daughter
came to you with a finance question my
daughter that came to me about about a
simple question about Donald cost
averaging but I said because you just
look at what I'm it's like this um this
uh motivation like this virtual
motivation where I really couldn't come
to my parents with a lot of questions
they didn't really have the answers they
just weren't those kind of people so I'm
like I can't now take that attitude into
my journey as a father here I'm gonna
have to do a little bit better and and
to be able to answer a little bit more
questions and the the thing that I'm
learning about is that we have a real
lack of Education or I have a real lack
of education on the things that actually
matter right so I
can tell you you know Civil War generals
and state capitals and things like that
but when it came down to bouncing a
checkbook when it came down to proper
Investments when it came down to making
my children's life easier
because money doesn't solve all problems
but it solves a lot of them sure just be
honest that
Finance was a thing that I'm like I have
a big weak spot here so how do I help
myself and you can you can ask the truth
is like anything else you have to learn
it yourself the only way to become an
expert at something is you have to get
to a point where you are so good at it
that you can begin to teach it to others
that's what it is so that's my goal that
I've said rather than trying to say how
am I going to make it in comedy I'm
going to do I love comedy I feel like
we're all experts in comedy we have our
10 000 hours so you keep doing comedy
you've we've studied that ship we're
going to keep getting better and keep
doing what we're doing being prolific
and all that but now this next part how
do I get how do I get good at finance
and how do I get good at making my kids
lives easier and I think that that can
come down to giving them a nice
structure with money like my daughter
and I she's going to be eight years old
next week and for her birthday for her
birthday we're gonna buy her first stock
we're gonna buy a stock for her and
we're gonna just let her pick what she
wants and she's going to watch that
stock and we're going to see
that's what we're gonna do we're going
to buy stock for it because you know I
didn't know because I've made some bad
Investments I don't have enough money
for this party you got to get them you
must have a birthday party like we're
gonna get a job a penny stock whatever
one you want how do you get two yeah two
stops yeah well I put [__] ninety
percent of our wealth in crypto honey so
so you can't get the party so so I just
try to think about things like and again
I actually my theory
because of our see here's here's another
thing right because we have a public
platform with podcasting I used to take
the approach oh I don't want to say I
don't want to say something and then
sound like an idiot because then the
people in the comments can call me an
idiot that's how you learn you know how
many stupid things I've said about
Finance the last six weeks and then
somebody comments hey you [__] dumb
[__] here's what you really should do
and then I eliminate the dumb [__]
eliminate and then I just again I should
have texted him
I just take what they say because they
probably are right and I Google it and
then I get a little bit better off what
the comments of the fan said so if you
want me to really listen call me a dumb
piece of [__] fat [__] and then give
me the Nugget of information and I'll
take them back on his insecurities
that's what I like to do yeah so that
that that's how I learned yeah I always
like when someone like says like a word
or something like a that other person
doesn't know like oh would you just
learn that word he's trying and it's
like okay yeah yeah I did I've tried it
on well now you learned it you know what
I mean like it's like I always I always
I'm like why do people say like it's
like behooved yeah my grandfather once
said to me I saw him I I watched this
example of a ticket meter right uh uh
the you know people give the tickets for
when your meters out this guy [__]
screaming at this meter maid screaming
at this meter maid and my grandfather
was there we were watching I was it was
like crazy like he was going to like
throw this guy like off through the
windshield and my grandfather was like
um
he was like I got so mad at like
whatever it is 30 ticket I was like yeah
you know I know I guess you just didn't
want to get the ticket he goes yeah but
you know that guy should ask himself
does he want to switch places with the
meter maid do you do you think the meter
maid wants to be the meter maid do you
think that that's what that guy wants to
do right with his life he wants to ruin
people's days if he does then that
personality then you sign up for TSA
then you sign up for TSA but if you
probably don't and using that stepping
stone it's like just be happy you're not
the meter maid take the ticket right as
a thirty dollars be like thank God I
don't have to do that every payment to
the universe pay that to the universe
that's it yeah that's what it is
I have uh ADHD pretty bad because I've
had good teeth though I want to say
three things while you guys are talking
I was like no problem I'll just remember
them three things in the last two
minutes and I forgot everyone start
saying them out loud and as they cover
them out blurt it out and then we'll and
then but we won't if you just yell
literally I had three things to say to
Ed right on the chalkboard I just felt
like you weren't talking to me no I was
like let me remember and then it happens
to me a lot
on the podcast it happens the whole
podcast long so I have an idea but I
don't want to make an interruption and
then he's done he's when someone's done
talking and then I'm like I'm trying to
pay attention and I'm like what was the
thing that I was trying to say and I
don't remember and I just go all right
yeah and I don't remember anything well
that's good radio it is good radio what
were you just talking about
um
um I we were talking about Finance
dollar question you're a finance major
both you guys I was accounting yeah wow
what do you do Fidelity no I live my I
live my life by the seat of my pants my
father died at the young age I'm burning
this [__] down I'm not leaving anything
behind these kids can make their own
life good and that's the strategy
I uh yeah I got I got when I got kids I
mean the kids is the Awakening you get
the kids it's like already so what do
you do you do
529.29 yeah their College is already
paid for yeah it's all it's all in there
got the 529s I got the Vanguard I gotta
I got a swap what I'm doing now here's
what I'm doing you ready for this
remember this okay here's what I'm doing
a little my this is my thing okay I am
now you know you diversify your
portfolio and you know we all do that
percentage stocks percentage Investments
blah blah blah but I'm now diversifying
the diversifiers what I'm doing is as
I'm saying I have a percentage of my
money with a a a a a financial planner
who takes one percent which starts to
add up so real money takes one percent
at Charles Schwab gave him the money
gladly even though yeah people say hey
getting one percent get [__] okay fine
let delegate trust an expert is fees one
percent great but simultaneously what
I'm doing is I have I'm managing my own
money as I'm learning in a Vanguard
account that I've set up that I'm paying
attention to I'm just all I'm doing is
kind of do what he's doing
just put money in index funds you know
that the big Fortune 500 companies and
I'm just looking how can I can I do that
for a much smaller percentage Vanguard
is like 0.005 so I'm like looking at
that I'm like okay and then with Chase
you can become a Chase
a private client and they will invest
your money and I've asked them to put
money in accounts uh or invest in in
things that have that certain uh
Investments that they do for you have no
commission fee certain funds they'll
invest have no commission so I'm like
give me some of those and I'm gonna put
all three up against each other in one
calendar year we started this a month
ago so next April right after tax season
I'm gonna say who got me the biggest
return yeah where did the biggest return
come from and then make an educated
decision from there as opposed to making
an emotional decision and listening to
half a podcast where they say financial
planners rip you off and then firing
your financial planner and now you're
stuck with no education and nothing to
do with your money I'm just spending
money to learn that's what I'm thinking
interesting and is is that because my
financial guy I got from you yeah and I
got from my my grandfather and father
I'm not anti-given we're living a
percentage-based business I'm just
trying to see can I educate myself and
do can I can I in this time also become
close to another you see a lot of that
you you see a lot of uh propaganda that
Financial of people rip you off there's
things not not that they rip you off not
that they're bad guys I don't even know
what my guy takes actually now that you
mentioned he's taking one percent at
least I don't know about that unless
you've worked out some deal where you
take an overall flat rate okay that's
pass one percent but typically one
percent for your 401k so you have a 401k
yeah right so you have a four oh yeah oh
yeah we gotta go so you have a 401k
right I'm sure we all have it you look
at it over the course of the years yes
it's getting a return not much because
the 401K is supposed to be not risky but
after the commission of the financial
planner you can realistically like there
are index funds let's take Vanguard I
just like Vanguard they're like steady
you could put your money in Vanguard and
get it's robotic the index funds there's
not that's not rocket science it's the
top 500 it's the Fortune 500 companies
the S P 500 it is those companies and
the apples those companies are not going
anywhere if they do we don't have a
country you can just put your money in
there and it'll get it's whatever return
over the 30 years historically is it
always gets 20 30 percent and that's and
that you'll get that money as opposed to
having a financial planner manager 401K
where they're taking one percent of it
now all of a sudden that hundred
thousand dollars say that you have in
your 401k would be 900 Grand by the time
you're 70. now it's 500 Grand because of
the fees when really like there's they
haven't done anything it's just the
money's a [__] Index Fund it's like
what it what is what is the rocket
science with apple and Microsoft right
they're humongous companies right so I'm
thinking about that and again I might
have just said something that's
completely ironic I'm gonna check the
comments and check the comments comments
the the experts in the comments will let
me know if I'm wrong or right sure and
then if they tell me how wrong I am I'll
research why and then I'll come back
here confidently and say something even
more wrong next week okay yeah
and the crypto that you had
the crypto Sal
what you ready for this no I'm I'm
wishing you a mental change in investing
strategy from the OG the goat Warren
Buffett okay Warren Buffett says never
he never invests in something he doesn't
understand I do not understand crypto
for the life of me but yet I invested in
it big mistake yeah not that I have
anything wrong with crypto I just don't
get it yeah so I put a small percentage
in it but I'm now thinking about taking
that money out might not be the smartest
idea right now because crypto crashed
and it's like might as well just leave
it and see what happens it's I'm gonna
at some point if it goes up take it out
because I just don't understand it and
put it in something I understand a
little bit more sure that's what I so
crypto was stupid of me because I didn't
understand it but I learned okay I
learned you take that out maybe put it
into something like put in my kids 529
cheesecake I'll put it into what
something you really understand
intermittent fasting intermittent
fasting yeah yes yes red velvet
cheesecakes speaking of which uh
like to watch good watch watch is our
good investment Joe's a big white watch
guy I'm a watch guy Joe's for the whites
that's one thing I know about watches
yeah he's open about it all the time I
say it yeah my Mantra yeah uh tell the
people way they can see you where you're
going to be you're on tour yeah all your
all your stuff oh let your people know
yeah I'm promoing yeah oh all right
great yeah come on out and see me
it's Joe gattoofficial.com how's my tour
dates just released on my full tour
dates uh taking the summer off to be
with the fam and then go hitting the
road again and uh yeah so you got any
good ones let's say let's see
oh my God I'm playing the Vic in Chicago
what do you love Montgomery Alabama the
capital is it I'm a clear world if I've
been in Florida doing Orlando's Miami's
I'm doing that there's a night Center in
Miami
uh no uh
[Laughter]
uh June 1st in San Angelo Texas going to
be a scorching I haven't done Texas yet
so I'm hitting that Texas you never know
what's gonna happen in auditory you just
showed up in Boston out of nowhere Joe
is on stage with us in Boston you owe me
a Poppin I do owe you a Poppin and
that's popped in your solo and I popped
in on you never know what's gonna happen
on that tour so impractical jokers.com
you might see Joe uh he came uh he came
to the show we were on stage I come back
off stage he had used our account he
ordered 300 worth of food
Seafood Tower Lobster everything spread
off 300 and he was just eating it I'm
like what'd you do he's like I just
ordered Foods you to a man
this is crazy it was delicious jumbo
lump crabby yeah
but there you go that's that's that show
God thank you for joining us thank you
for having me good to see you thank you
love you babe all right this has been
hey babe it's been hey babe
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
[Music]